monsieur le garde des sceaux vous vous
dites je vous cite ulcéré du procès qui
est fait au gouvernement à propos des
15000 places de prison que le président
de la république s'est engagé à
construire pendant son quinquennat
et moi je suis également une serré mais
pas pour les mêmes raisons je suis
ulcéré qu'on prétende on puisse oser
prétendre que cet engagement a été tenu
qu'on en juge
deux mille places ont été ouvertes la
santé des baumettes 2 x 2 c'est-à-dire
des travaux engagés par monsieur jean
jacques urvoas garde des sceaux du
précédent quinquennat ça fait 2000
places 650 places sont en cours de
réalisation
c'est tout pas plus même si il faut le
dire des marchés sont notifiées pour
trois mille quatre cent cinquante places
qui malheureusement pour la plupart
d'entre elles prendront plusieurs années
avant d'être ouverte cet échec grave
cette carence dans le respect des
engagements qui sont au coeur d'un
mandat présidentiel pose un véritable
problème démocratique et puis il ya la
question du budget
parce que l'augmentation des moyens
d'injustice est réel et je crois qu'il
faut le reconnaître mais elle aura été
insuffisante au départ et ceci ne sera
pas rattrapé
irrégulière sur la durée avec une sous
consommation de crédits qui constitue
une anonyme une anomalie graves dans le
fonctionnement de l'état la loi de
programmation pour la justice a été
votée tardivement elle prévoyait une
augmentation de crédit de 23 % en cinq
ans nous avons jugé que c'était
insuffisant qu'il fallait atteindre si
possible 30% nous n'avons donc pas voter
vous avez décidé de rétablir la
trajectoire que nous souhaitions ne
pouvons pas vous le reprocher dans
sommes heureux mais pour autant nous ne
pouvons pas vous laisser dire que les
forfaits pour la justice permet une
remise à niveau telles qu'elles seraient
nécessaires pour le bon fonctionnement
de la justice d'abord parce qu on ne
rattrapera pas les sous dotation des
premières années du quinquennat cet
argent qui n'a pas été dépensée ne le
sera plus deuxièmement la sous
consommation anémique des crédits de la
mission justice y faisait allusion
excusez-moi
378 millions pour les années 2010 8 2019
et 2020 de sous-consommation mêmes
s'agissant des crédits d'investissement
et c'est le plus grave est ailleurs ça
explique en grande partie ce qu'on
construit pas de places de prison
652 millions
soit un tiers des crédits
d'investissement de ces trois années qui
n'ont pas été engagées c'est très grave
on ne peut pas accepter cette situation
enfin le caractère purement virtuelle du
budget 2022 qui n'engage à rien et
d'ailleurs n'est pas soutenable fait que
la bataille budgétaire sera entièrement
à recommencer au second semestre 2022 et
alors il sera trop tard pour tenir la
trajectoire budgétaire de 2022 c'est
pourquoi il faut pas se contenter de
voir les crédits votés il faut regarder
quel aura été est respectivement
l'effort réel en faveur de la justice et
je vous le dis le compte n'y est pas
que vous le vouliez ou non monsieur le
sénateur
il y avait huit 1427 magistrats au 1er
janvier 2017
nous en sommes à 9090
c'est vrai et c'est incontestable et 52
plus viendront abonder ce nombre
en plus naturellement nous pourvoirons
au départ à la retraite
ce que nous avons fait
pardon mais c'est vous qui avait donné
cette tournure politicienne vous ne
l'avez pas fait
il y avait en 2017 monsieur le sénateur
bas un taux de vacances chez les
magistrats de 6,22 %
il est au 1er novembre 2021 de
0,56 pour cent
oui vous avez dit le contraire dans un
discours un peu fumeux purement
politicien à eau souffrait souffrez que
je vous réponde je vous réponds avec des
chiffres vous comprenez je vous réponds
avec des chiffres parce qu à vous
entendre nous n'avons rien fait lemay
pardon j'ai la parole un instant
souffrez que je vous réponde je vais
vous répondre parce que c'est
insupportable
la critique pour la critique le on va
continuer on va continuer chez les
greffiers
chez les glaciers oui un peu de respect
parce qu'on a respecté notre travail la
caisse punchs et les greffiers à
monsieur garde des sceaux et l nos
collègues sénateurs de bien vouloir
baisser d'un ton dans la forme et sur le
fond bien sûr madame la présidente
c'est de tout ce qui s'oppose mais moi
je vous opposez des chiffres pas le
sentiment de n'avoir rien fait depuis je
suis à la chancellerie et pardon de vous
les rappeler parce que sur les chiffres
hoyau on peut difficilement contester
s'agissant des fonctionnaires des
personnels de greffe
dysfonctionnements ont été recrutés
suite notamment départ à la retraite
entre 2017 et 2021
s'agissant des délais puisque vous avez
dit
ça s'est aggravé nos compatriotes
attendent d'eux une justice plus rapide
j'ai lu d'ailleurs monsieur le sénateur
bas dans un esprit construction joly les
travaux dont vous avez parlé hier
et me sens très utile parce que je
partage les constats qui sont les autres
mais il est faux de dire que les stocks
ont augmenté parce que nous ne les
aurions pas traitées ils ont augmenté
parce que il y a eu ce qu'on ne peut pas
encore oublié même si on peut s'exprimer
sans masque à la tribune l'aco vide
et une grève des avocats qui a duré six
mois
à qui la faute c'est siècle c'est à qui
la faute vous n'avez jamais connu grèves
quand vous étiez au pouvoir c'est une
évidence mais peu importe c'est ça qui a
fait que les stocks ont remonté mais
qu'il madame de la gontrie ne vous en
déplaise si vous souhaitiez
m'accompagner quand je vais dans les
juridictions où verriez que dans toutes
les juridictions où je vais les stocks
j'ai bien compris mais les chiffres que
l'un des vôtres a donné tout à l'heure
sur nîmes et nantes sont faux jeu les
corriger j'étais encore hier à nanterre
et la présidente du tj nanterre m'a dit
à quel point les stocks diminuent et
pourquoi parce que nous avons envoyé en
masse des personnels à la fois pour le
civil aussi pour le pénal pour le civil
ce sont des juristes assistants et quand
un juriste assistants et aux côtés d'un
magistrat c'est deux fois plus de
décisions dans le même temps s'agissant
des établissements pénitentiaires parce
que vous avez fait le tour de la
politique pénale que je conduis pour
mieux la critique et au fond vous avez
assez peu critiqué mon texte et vous
avez fait une espèce de deux tours comme
ça à 360 degrés c'est un mot de cette
expression je voudrais vous dire que
sont sortis de terre lesdites les
établissements pénitentiaires de
luterbach tout neuf voyez-vous tout neuf
et que si vous allez monsieur le
sénateur bas à caen en avignon hameau à
lille à owni et j'en oublie vous verrez
les 7000 places qui seront livrés en
2022 2023 quant aux îles
le président de la république a dit en
qu'il y aurait au total quinze mille
places d'ici 10 ans et en 2027 toutes
les places seront livrés soit 75 mille
place nette sans compter les réfections
naturellement nous avons pris en
considération et c'était bien légitime
les conditions de détention fleury
mérogis le savez vous monsieur le
sénateur a été complètement complètement
restauré naturellement
certains chez vous on dit 80000 nous
aurions dit 80000 certains c'est voudras
aurait dit qu'à travers sa demie alors
je veux également vous dire que vous
avez pas de leçons à nous donner / / / /
jce par donc c'est vous qui l'avait
placé sur ce terrain vous avez supprimé
des policiers et nous nous avons franchi
la barre des 9000 90 magistrat cet
historique
non non monsieur le sénateur ça ne
durera pas 20 ans mais ça durera le
temps que vous nous ferez le grief de ne
pas avoir été présent sur le régalien et
tant que vous ne ferez vous ne constatez
pas que nous en avons fait plus
pendant cette mandature que vous durant
de bien plus nombreuses années voilà je
termine je termine mes mais souffrez que
je vous réponde vous voudriez qu'ici je
vienne à canossa la tête baissée pour
dire on n'a rien offert mais c'est une
plaisanterie
souffrez que je vous réponds que je vais
encore vous répondre
[Musique]